hello everyone
welcome to the panel discussion on the
current standards of care
in lung cancer i'm dr andrew so
associate director
medical and scientific liaison group in
apple diagnostics
i hope you have enjoyed the two
pre-recorded presentations by dr
maizon and dr hanesh
so before we go into the panel
discussion i would like to quickly
summarize the key points from these two
presentations we have heard that most
lung cancer diagnosis are preceded by
detection of a lung nodule by chest ct
imaging
now while majority of these models are
still found incidentally
screening detected modules are on the
rise
with an estimated 1.5 million nodules
detected per year
over an estimated 5 million people
several landmark studies demonstrated
that early detection of lung cancer
is a powerful approach to reducing
mortality
and improving patient outcomes
unfortunately lung cancer is often
asymptomatic
until later stages therefore
screening of high-risk individuals
allows detection of lung modules
that are or may become cancerous at a
much earlier time point
the nlst and the nelson trials
demonstrated the benefits
of low-dose ct screening for lung cancer
the dante trial did not find a
significant benefit
for low-dose ct screening furthermore
the potential benefit of screening is
diminished by the uh
false positive ct results as a majority
of the modules number time
which could lead to unnecessary and
potentially
harmful invasive procedures
now several new serum biomarkers
currently under investigation are
available
to help detect early stage lung cancer
for example plasma dna levels
may improve the accuracy of ct screening
for lung cancer
now it is also apparent that biomarker
panels are more effective when combined
with
single parameters for early detection of
lung cancer
so that brings us now to this panel
discussion
right so this panel discussion is mainly
focused on
early detection of lung cancer and today
we are privileged
to have three esteemed experts with us
we have dr darren lim who is the
associate professor and senior
consultant
of the division of medical oncology at
national cancer center singapore
we also have dr arjun karna a senior
consultant
in interventional pulmonology critical
care
allergy and sleep medicine at yashoda
hospital in new delhi we have
dr david lam who is a clinical associate
professor
from hong kong university with interest
in
transitional research and clinical
trials
unfortunately professor lai could not be
with us
due to some urgent matters
okay so and now i would like to ask each
of the panelists
to provide a brief on your current role
in your institution
in the diagnosis and management of lung
cancer
so maybe we could start with dr darren
lim please
hi everyone i'm dr lim i'm a medical
oncologist by training
and my focus has really been in lung
cancer
and head and neck cancers my day job is
a medical oncologist
but i also moonlight as a the research
director for
uh the lung singh health lung disease
center which brings together
the multidisciplinary groups in
in singh health singapore health
services
and i also am the coordinating pi
for lung cancer screening study in
singapore specifically looking at
incorporating biomarkers emerging
biomarkers into ldct
screening protocols for both
traditionally high-risk
groups as well as low-risk populations
thank you
yeah so being a pulmonologist you know
in india i work as a multi-purpose
worker i have to coordinate between the
patients the oncologist
so my job begins at suspecting lung
cancer
when the patient walks into my opd and
you know as a pulmonologist you order
scans
and when you read them a basic job is to
provide tissue
so we do a lot of interventional
pulmonology procedures i'm in charge of
the interventional pulmonology labs so i
do bronchoscopies e-bus
racoscopies and we give the tissue to
our pathologists and our medical
oncologist colleagues
and apart from that giving them the
tissue diagnosis we do a lot of you know
we help them in managing the
complications of these patients putting
in plural catheters
you know if they have any perineoplastic
syndromes managing those
taking care of the clinical profile the
clinical management of these patients in
india most of the times
would be done by a pulmonologist in you
know conjugation with a medical
oncologist
and that is what we do we diagnose our
patients we give the tissue for
diagnosis
and then we step in to manage these
patients with our own quality colleagues
that's what i do with my patients of
lung cancer
thank you dr david
oh thank you um i'm a
pulmonologist by training and i have a
research interest and
lung cancer so besides those different
respiratory illnesses like copd
in the tissue i also manage patients
with
lung cancer and at the same time doing
laboratory translational and also
clinical trials
and patients with lung cancer and i also
do the
um some of the intervention procedures
for patients like ebers
an autofluorescence bronchoscopy and
as a pulmonologist we do receive a lot
of
referrals for incidental finding of
lung no jews and so we have to
we are very eager to develop um
biomarkers
or management protocols for
patients who've just been referred to us
for management of lung modules for
further investigation
and i'm running also
reduced studies and i've joined the
international
lung screening consortium
steering the lung screening projects in
highway
smokers with the um canadian groups and
also the australian groups
and screening patients um
screening high with smokers in the local
population
for early detection of lung cancer thank
you
okay thank you great so
now i would like to pose the first
question to dr
arjun right we know that the early
detection of lung cancer
can lead to better and faster decision
making
and effective planning of treatment so
what are the current challenges in the
early diagnosis of lung cancer in your
practice
in india and what is your opinion on
overcoming these challenges
fabulous so dr andrew as you said you
know the early presentation of lung
cancer the early symptoms of lung cancer
are very often missed
and most of the times in india patients
come to us when the disease is already
metastatic
you know the majority of our patients we
just analyzed our group majority of what
we do 78
of patients in my practice are already
stage four by the time they come to us
and 22 percent are 3b already
so you know in india most of the times
we are looking at palliative care for
our patients with lung cancer
the biggest problem is because the
symptoms are non-specific
and in india if someone gets an audio on
a ct scan or a chest x-ray most of the
times the primary diagnosis
is given as pulmonary tuberculosis or
some kind of a chest infection
so the biggest challenge in my practices
before
patients come to us invariably the
patients have been on three months four
months of anti-tubercular therapy
patients have been empirically being
treated for tv and other lung infections
and by the time they come to you the
patient is already
has you know they have advanced disease
another big problem in india is that we
do not have a formal screening program
in our country you know whether it is
high risk patients or other patients
there is no insurance backup there is no
formal government or private sector
program
when you know you try and screen
high-risk patients
different universities different
hospitals have tried to follow the
nelson project
and you know accordingly screen patients
but then most of the times because there
is no impetus there is no support
to do that so most of us have tried to
run screening programs
but unfortunately majority of them fell
flat so we were not able to really do it
when it comes to the peripheral parts of
the country the interiors of the country
there is problem in the availability of
low-dose ct scans
in the availability of you know
bronchoscopy swedes
so a lot of these patients will be
treated empirically only on the basis of
a chest x-ray or a sputum examination
and availability of ct scans in a lot of
part of our country would be a big
problem
and even if a ct scan is done and the
patient shows an incidental nodule
or you know something that looks like a
mass lesion
majority of these patients would still
not be referred to us
for tissue diagnosis they would be given
a trial of att anti-tuberculosis therapy
for at least two
three months before you know they
actually start developing bad symptoms
and then they would be referred to a
pulmonology practice
for further evaluation another problem
dr andrew here
is that even if you pick up you know
early lung cancer
you pick it up you pick up a nodule
you've done a pet ct in a high risk
patient and you see that
you know there is an audio and it looks
back to you it looks suspicious
there's this problem of availability of
thoracic surgeons we
you know even in a city like delhi which
is the capital city of my country
i can count on my fingers the number of
people who do you know lobectomy is the
number of people
who do open thoracotomies or wax surgery
now when you compare that to the rest of
the country these data is going to be
even worse
so even if you pick them up early there
are not many places that you can send
them to
wherein you know people can do something
to actually help the patient to
give them a tissue diagnosis to do a
thoracotomy or to do a vag procedure and
take out the nodule and tell us what we
are dealing with
so there are a lot of problems you know
when it comes to picking up early
you know lung cancer in this part of the
world
and to overcome this challenge well it's
going to take a lot of time
we need to first sensitize our
physicians especially the ones the
general physicians the gps who are
working in the peripheries in the
interiors of the country
that not everything that they see on the
chest x-ray is pulmonary tuberculosis
they need to be you know
told to think about lung cancer in the
first place
and that it is a big problem in our
country if you look at the
morbidity and mortality due to cancers
in india lung cancer is the number one
cause of mortality in our country but
even then it is unfortunately missed
we need to open the government agencies
and the bodies to start
some kind of a screening program which
is suitable to our country
and when i talk about that you know i'm
not talking about something which is
very high fangled which would include
something like radiology or which would
include low dose cities
because in our country that would not be
feasible so i think
in my country if this program has to
take up
if we need to pick up lung cancer early
apart from sensitizing our physicians we
need to have a blood marker
the ideal blood marker would be
something that would not only give you
the diagnosis of lung cancer but would
also tell you the stage of the disease
and would also tell you what kind of a
lung cancer you are dealing with but as
of now it seems like a distant dream
but if i could you know sum it up in one
go in india patients are not averse to
getting blood tests
and you know getting a ct scan at times
for our patients
is difficult so if there is a biomarker
which we can do early
if there is something which is you know
which has been proven scientifically
that it works
i think that would solve a lot of our
problems in our country
okay thank you is that also the same
experience in singapore and hong kong
maybe we try hong kong first oh um
we shared a similar experience with um
in the sen in terms of the um
the problems that dr khanna has
mentioned and
we have a high prevalence of
tuberculosis
or older tuberculosis in this part of
asia not limited to india not limited to
hong kong
and now indeed i can tell you um the
first abnormal low-dose ct
results that i've got in my uh in the
screening program that i've run
was actually my patients with
tuberculosis
so tuberculosis is one problem
the other one i will think of is
we definitely need a
better biomarkers in screening the
targeted population so we may be talking
about smoking
who has one of the major risk factors
in identifying subjects for screening
for early detection but at the same time
we also
have a prominent group of
patients with lung cancers who are
indeed
lifetime never smokers and we don't have
good going
biomarkers or clinically identifiable
risk factors for them
so in those situations
we need also biomarkers to help
in better defining who the screen
and how we screen
okay dr lim
um yeah i think i think this
experience be fairly similar in terms of
the
uh you know we have guidelines
uh introduced in just recently last year
on
low-dose ct screening for high-risk
individuals
but again how much of it is being
embraced and actually
taken up by the the public i think
that's
something that is not very apparent
um getting them to that first ct for the
high risk population i think probably is
going to be
the first obstacle that we need to get
to and then subsequently to adhere to
subsequent
uh screening um nodal ct screening
if they pick up something and then
subsequently getting them
past that obstacle of going on to
interventional
biopsies and to prove whether or not
they have cancer
i think these are all common obstacles
that we
we see and having a biomarker that could
potentially
enrich or suggest a higher probability
of
cancer and then combining that with the
low-dose ct screening may be the way
forward
okay so talking about
a high-risk population right i mean you
know
dr messions in his lecture he mentioned
about
30 of lung cancer in southeast asia
are non-smokers right so you know
um and and if that is the case
right um you know who are these high
risk people that we should be looking
out for other than smokers
right which is the obvious case
are you addressing it to anyone in
particular any anyone
i'll take the first bite uh since uh
okay
all right okay i said i think the
that proportion actually may be higher
than 30 percent you know from
for us probably around half of the
patients would be
more going to be not never smokers and
i think the taiwanese group did try to
address that in some way but in the
talent
study they enrich for a family history
of lung cancer in uh
i think up to second degree relatives
and reach for
exposure to secondhand smoke or cooking
fumes
using a cooking index and also
and together that seemed to improve
the low-dose ct screening rate compared
to
purely low-dose ct screening
strategy so i think that could be one
way to go
in terms of using a clinical algorithm
to pick up this patients at risk
thank you thank you yeah
all right yeah i agree with dr lim and
the um talent study in taiwan actually
did get a better um detection rate
of um lung cancer from the
um the european trials of um around one
point something percent
um they've got um slightly more than two
percent of detection
with those 2.4 i think yeah
2.45 something and um but it's still
um no and we
definitely are facing a very unique
population in the um
itself in the asian part here
and indeed
it varies with the smoking prevalence
in the population in hong kong we only
have a ten percent of a smokies
in the population so um
we are bound to face a lot of patients
who have who
will have lung cancer found or diagnosed
or detected early
from non-smokers so there is an urgent
need to
identify a good going biomarkers
to try to help screening for
or early detection of lung cancer in
this part of the world
okay thank you all right so
that brings us to the next question um
so the next question i'll direct to dr
david
uh so you know you did mention that
there
you know that is a use of biomarkers so
um you know what in in your opinion on
the use of biomarkers in the era
of low-dose ctu just alluded to it a
little bit maybe can you expand a little
bit more
and you know on the same vein right we
are talking about low dose ct
so what is your opinion on the pros and
cons of using
low-dose ct in early detection of lung
cancer
what i believe is low dose ct
is a good and effective way
of screening for lung cancer as
an initial tools but um
is good in the sense that it's effective
not only in finding something but in
finding
a lot of different things including
those indeterminate
nodules tuberculosis or
even some supplies that sometimes to us
besides those lung nodules that are
eventually diagnosed to be lung cancer
so that's why is again is good
and not good enough tools that
is not that specific that it only tells
you there is something abnormal there
you need for example substantive
subsequent work of pulmonologists or
intervention pulmonologists
to get the tissue for the diagnosis or
even
to to make it um to
diagnose it away from lung cancer
whether it is tb
or other pathology so
it's good as an initial screening but we
need
um uh what we say uh
complementary tools in the subsequent
workup
when something has been found on the
local city
is um is good but the
availability in some countries as dr
khanna mentioned
would be another issue so um
the world cup is another issue and
um that the another issue that i've
alerted to
um in the previous discussion
is that local city is not um
what we say um specifically
um useful for a particular population
is um designed for general purpose
so um it appears to be good in different
populations
just like in the corporations or in
asians but at the same time
is again not specific
towards the population characteristics
or the so-called hybrid population so
if we have an additional biomarkers
to um go with low dose dt or to
follow when something has been found on
nodocity
that would be good when i say biomarkers
is not limited to
blood biomarkers but it could be other
biomarkers like
some of the radiological features for
example now the
city can say whether the nodules
actually um calcified
in nature whether there is damage solid
whether they're brown glass components
or or wholly solid component sometimes
that among other features of the
textures
could act as a biomarkers as to guide
subsequent investigation for example if
they are mostly calcified
most of the time we believe that they
are the results of
old tuberculosis or indeed if some of
them has a significant
ground grass um what was it ground grass
a component
then we would be more worried and we
need to be more aggressive in the
subsequent
intervention or management
concerning um low dose ct when i say as
good as an initial tool
um there are two situations to arise
one is when it finds something for you
then you go on investigations as we have
mentioned
but another issue is when the local city
is not giving you anything it's for
example telling you that it's normal
so what's the subsequent um
frequency to screen what will be the
appropriate
frequency to screen subsequently for
these are high risk populations
just like the situation with um
colorectal tumors
sometimes the colorectal surgeons
or the um the current guidelines will
recommend
in high-risk individuals they have to
have
colonoscopic surveillance and subsequent
years
but we don't have such ideas such
information
when it comes to low dose ct for lung
screening
so um so i would say low dose ct is a
good as an initial tool
but we need the complementary
tools and subsequent work up in order to
make it
useful for screening and early detection
of lung cancer
great great thank you so okay so moving
on to the
you know i'm describing the tools right
which i just mentioned maybe i'd like to
ask um
dr darren lim right giving that uh
risk stratification of high-risk
patients can be a game changer as you
mentioned
for early detection of lung cancer what
is your opinion
on risk stratification tools for
detection of lung cancer at early stages
and the potential role of newer
biomarkers in risk stratification of
high-risk patients
we can't hear you okay sorry i muted
myself
great question andrew um i think the
risk stratification tools in the form of
minimally invasive biomarkers as
alluded to by dr khanna and dr lam
before are gonna be uh potential game
changes
um you know it would allow us to perhaps
enrich an even a higher within a
high-risk population pick up
was an even higher risk for uh
potential uh cancer and uh direct
the appropriate uh limited medical
interventions to that particular group
um you know i personally favor perhaps
some breath or blood-based biomarkers
that have been specifically designed
with detecting early-stage
lung cancers in mind i i think the broad
pan cancer approaches such as grail
mail be a bit more challenging as the
biomarkers may not be fit for purpose
nor necessarily applicable to early
stage
disease i think
a very nice biomarker which is recently
reported in our world
i think in one of the uh iaslc meetings
uh comes from ankimun and
this was a randomized controlled trial
uh which will involve about 12 000
individuals in scotland
and what they actually showed um
and this was a high-risk population for
patients who were high-risk of
developing lung cancer
and they were able to demonstrate that
more people were detected with early
lung cancer in the
intervention arm the screening arm
compared to the standard arm
of just observation i think the numbers
of about 41 percent versus 26 percent
and this also reduced the late stage
lung cancer detection
uh late stage lung cancer
deaths at two years in the in the
intervention arm
so um i think this is a very nice
demonstration of
of the utility of uh of a blood-based
biomarker
uh together with uh lodo ct uh in in in
a
high-risk population the caveats of this
trial being that this is only one trial
and we
haven't really repeated it in another
population
and in a similar design and the question
again is it
applicable to asian population this was
a totally
western scottish population and does the
panel perform any differently in asians
does it perform the same for say a lower
risk population
a lifetime never smoker population i
think these are questions that
remain to be answered yeah
okay thank you all right so
now i'm going to ask each of you
panelists a question
and i would like you to provide a yes no
answer
with a short justification for your
answer okay
are you ready let's start with dr arjun
right okay do you think
non-invasive methods like biomarkers are
easy to implement and are effective
tools
for screening of lung cancer yes or no
so despite being an interventional
pulmonologist my answer is
yes because at times you know especially
in the covered era you want to
probably not do as much intervention you
know as we used to do we are now moving
away from interventions we want to delay
it as much as possible
and of course at times you know it is
not always economically feasible
the logistics sometimes especially in
our country do not allow us to do
biopsies a lot of patients who have lung
cancer
unfortunately the elderly smokers they
would also have severe copd ipf
ild and subjecting them to an
interventional pulmonology procedure or
an open surgery for diagnosis at times
is not possible so yes
if there is a simple way out a blood or
a breath-based test
which can complement us in the diagnosis
of lung cancer
the ideal would be if it can also tell
us the prognosis and the type the
subtype the histological subtype
of the lung cancer but then that's
thinking out that's thinking out loud
and thinking about too far
but yes of course if there is such a
biomarker
absolute thumbs up would be absolutely
welcome
okay thank you right so um the next
target
dr darren lim okay so i'm going to give
you a statement and
you let me know whether you agree with
this statement or not right
so it says repeat ct is not an effective
and robust approach
for screening of lung cancer do you
agree with this statement yes or no
i don't agree with the statement i think
it can be an effective
tool but it needs a lot of work i think
studies have shown
that if we can get the patient to the
first ct
and they will adhere to potentially
annual screening programs
we also know that in certain developed
countries
the isa for for such uh
low-dose ct screening is quite
cost-effective
and acceptable for these countries to
implement on a broad scale
i think also you know but i think there
are also entrenched
beliefs and perceptions of radiation
risk and screening
and biopsies and i don't want to know
that i got cancer
thinking you know in asian countries and
this i think this need public education
to overcome
and and get the patients high risk to
onto these
screening programs okay
thank you all right so i believe we have
dr
david lum okay
right the question for you is do you
think that uh introduction of biomarkers
to ruling
or rule out lung cancer among patients
with indeterminate
pulmonary nodules would have tremendous
clinical benefit
yes or no um
i would view these statements in
different parts
i would say introduction of biomarker
is definitely yes good and
we always would like to have more tools
whether
they are able to rule in or rule out
lung cancer among patients with
indeterminate
pulmonary nodules is another story that
we need to
take care of because um that rests on
how good these biomarkers are
and so we would like to have
new tools that means we would like to
have additional biomarkers
um on top of a low-dose ct
and again not but our markets would be
good but
we would not limit to it but um like
those
radiological features they could
be evaluated to see how good they are in
ruling
in and out of lung cancer in that
specific
population of patients within
determining
pulmonary nodules if their performance
is good
are of good sensitivity and good
specificity
then they the introduction of these
good biomarkers should bring tremendous
clinical benefits
to our patients in the early detection
of an cancer
okay thank you thank you dr lam
right so finally um to round up this
discussion
right i would like to um you know to
know your concluding thoughts
on um what is the youtube let's say new
biomarkers and models
like lung cancer biomarker panels which
includes
biomarkers like pro-grp cyphrus 21-1
scca in combination with radiology
for early detection of lung cancer in
high-risk patients right
so maybe we'll start with dr arjun you
know
to give any final thoughts on that
i would need more data on that i need
more indian data on that whether that
works in our population or not so we all
know that these markers have been around
for a long period of time unfortunately
they're not a part of any of the
guidelines as of now
so once yes they are validated and they
are validated in our population because
as you know when you talk about
different populations
for example the south east asian
phenotype where you say 50
of your patients are non-smokers in my
country 90 of them are actually smokers
we have non-smoker lung cancer but
that's like really minority
so if these markers this panel has been
validated
in our country we have indian data to
support it
why not okay
thank you so uh dr darren lim
right your thoughts i think it's
potentially useful um radiomic models
which were suggested in the one of the
talks um
are reproducible if the same protocol
the same
machine the operator characteristics are
adopted
you know and you know in a broad manner
across the different institutions which
actually
apply that model if you have uh
different
ways of in doing that algorithm you
might end up with a
different readout so i think there are
limitations to that to the utility of
that radiomics model
um so that has been taken into
consideration biomarkers may refine of
course
may add on to that equation a bit more
and again as what uh david was
suggesting you know that
you know we really need to have good
specificity and fairly good sensitivity
for
for such biomarkers or to be applied
broadly
and finally i think uh which is the most
challenging part
is actually to uh the requirement for
properly designed and
empowered validation studies uh to to
prove that this
combination is actually going to be
useful
okay thank you so finally dr lam
one is the same as dr khan and dr lim
and i believe
these um newer panels of biomarkers are
always
potentially useful and but they need to
be
further validated when they are applied
to
um different populations of different
risk factor characteristics and
and as mentioned by dr khan and dr lim
um we need further evaluation of these
panels as well as their combination use
with other panels of biomarkers
or sometimes have to involve radio mix
or clinical features
okay great all right i think um
you know i think that basically sums up
very nicely
so uh i think you know if you've gone
through the
lectures and you've also listened to
this um panel discussion
uh if all of us agree that um you know
doing
just lodo ct alone um is good
uh but you know you would like to have
additional tools
right that could help you with the early
diagnosis and especially early detection
of lung cancer especially in this part
of the world
where it's so varied and in terms of the
use of lung cancer biomarker panels
you need more data especially data
specific to your local population
because it appears that there is a
population to population variation that
needs to be accounted for
right so i think in conclusion i would
like to thank the panelists for taking
time off your busy schedules
to share with us your expertise uh and
to the audience for joining us today
all right i hope you have found the
session informative and useful
so with that i would like to on behalf
of the panelists wish everyone a good
day
and stay safe thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you